bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
deux semaines après les élections
européennes
nous allons nous pencher sur le nouveau
paysage politique français sortis des
urnes
et comme il faut toujours regarder
l'élection suivante s'avère les
municipales du printemps prochain que
nous allons nous tourner avec pour les
deux forces qui ont dominé cette
élection et qui auront après le brésil
23 sièges chacune
la secrétaire départementale de
côte-d'or du rassemblement du
rassemblement national sylvie beaulieu
bonjour bonjour avec nous aussi le
député la république en marge de
côte-d'or didier paris ce bon jour pour
une des grandes victimes de cette
élection les républicains qui ont perdu
on va le rappeler deux millions de voix
entre deux élections européennes le
secrétaire départemental de la nièvre
jacques baudot un bonjour bonjour et
merci d'être avec nous sur ce plateau et
pour la troisième force de ces élections
europe ecologie les verts 13 pour ça on
le rappelle faire mal à rebours mesure
en vous présentant j'ai essayé de le
faire comme ça j'ai planté le décor de
cette élection
on peut le qualifier de scénario inédit
avec deux forces
quasiment à égalité et surtout un parti
au pouvoir qui n'est pas réellement
sanctionnés à mi mandat ce qui est ça
n'est pas forcément ce que l'ambiance
sociale annoncé didier paris sont vos
suppose soulagé après six mois de gilet
jaune de vous retrouver à ce niveau là
dans les urnes c'est pas une question de
soulagement par contre vous eu raison
d'insister
traditionnellement c'est un vote
intermédiaires qui est très défavorable
au pouvoir en place hollande la dernière
fois elle avait très mal vécu et et
beaucoup auparavant
donc ça montre finalement c'était bien
une élection européenne
ça prouve que parce que c'était dans
votre question le grand débat a été
traitée et la sortie du grand débat a
été traitée avec avec une compréhension
de ce que on a un gouvernement et une
classe politique qui fait tout pour
redresser la france et ce que nous
faisons avec un président la république
on lui a reproché mais en réalité
comment pouvait-il faire autrement qui
s'est fortement investie donc le
résultat n'est jamais satisfaisant nous
aurions préféré être devant il faut le
dire
09 points d'écart ils sont là mais c'est
un résultat si on regarde la nature de
cette élection par rapport aux
précédentes qui est un bon résultat
c'est un bon résultat pour
wihr et on va y venir l'avenir en
général et l'avenir électoral
sylvie beaulieu est ce que en revanche
ce mouvement social vous vous pensez
qu'ils vous a aussi favorisé que vous en
avez été les bénéficiaires
je ne suis pas certaine par contre vous
avez quand même tendance à minimiser le
score du front national du rassemblement
national pardon qui est arrivé en tête
on assiste maintenant à la confirmation
de cette rue by polyrey bipolarisation
rassemblement national la reine qui se
substitue en fait à cet ancien bataille
ump s ce qui fait aujourd'hui un
rassemblement national devant avec la
seule force politique d'alternance
crédible
à mon sens donc confirmation pour vous
après les présidentielles à votre
deuxième tour de la présidentielle tout
à fait claire mallard le bon résultat
écologistes c'est souvent est
caractéristique des européennes mais
souvent ça a tendance à fondre assez
vite derrière est ce que cette élection
européenne là elle est comme les autres
ou es ce que vous avez largement
bénéficié d'une ambiance nationale
internationale
très tourné vers le climat écoutez
c'était une élection européenne on a
parlé d'europe on écologistes on a parlé
d'écologie on a fait une campagne
positive sur des solutions alors qu'en
fait en face on avait des appels à voter
contre contre l'europe contre macron
contre le fn est en gros des votes de
résignation et les jeunes se sont pas
trompés qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils
attendent des actes forts pour un avenir
meilleur
et ils ont donc voté pour l'espoir mais
effectivement ça c'est notre campagne
mais on a eu un fort mouvement social en
faveur du climat et qui a porté aussi ce
vote écologiste
on a dit que le grand débat c'est une
façon de faire campagne mais on pourrait
dire aussi que les marches pour le
climat c'était pour vous une façon de
faire campagne
bien sûr la société bouge le mouvement
social bouche donc ça bouge aussi
politiquement c'est une sorte de relais
en fait des attentes de la société
civile qui s'est transformé en vote et
notamment de ces jeunes qui portent le
climat et qui se sont retrouvés sur une
proposition car comporter l'avenir et je
reviendrai tout à l'heure sur la
dangerosité en fait de présenter le
nouveau périmètre politique sous la
forme de la bipolarisation
moi je vois plutôt trois pôles qui sont
en train d'émerger mais gervinho riez
vite mais il ya aussi jacques baudoin on
a beaucoup notez bien sûr là les grandes
difficultés de des républicains dans
cette campagne save a été marquée par un
choix c'est celui d'une tête de liste
très marquée politiquement va dire à
droite du champ politique des
républicains
est ce que vous faisiez partie de ceux
qui partageaient cette ligne ou est ce
que vous faisiez partie de ceux qui
pensaient que c'était extrêmement risqué
ah non pas du tout moi je faisais partie
de la ligne vos pieds sans aucune sans
aucun problème
enfin j'aimerais bien relativiser cette
élection quand même on a l'impression de
la république qui avait utilisé les
médias pendant plus de cent heures avec
eux leur entrée le grand débat qui a
coûté très cher et qui n'a servi
strictement à rien et ensuite il s'est
impliqué directement dans la campagne
avec des magnifiques s'affiche enfin ce
que les force est de constater que
d'autres résidents ont fait aux
européennes précédemment nommé patrick
swim elvire en général c'est pas nouveau
mais ne m'en parle de ça et là on a
constaté quand même que
je veux être le premier il second ce
qu'un coureur cycliste qui courent et
qui arrive deuxième il n'a pas gagné
pardonnez moi mais en général j'aime
bien pour faire avancer le débat qu'on
réponde aux questions jarrie audouin la
question c'est est est ce que la ligne
françois-xavier bellamy très marquée par
sens commun par les manifs du mariage
pour tous elle était elle était de la
manif pour tous pardon est ce que
c'était est-ce que c'était pas une
erreur ou est-ce que c'était une
stratégie pour je regarde sylvie
beaulieu à côté de vous essayer de
garder vos électeurs pour pas qu'ils
aillent au rassemblement national bon
moi je peux vous dire qu'il y en a qui
ont été ceux qui sont élus au concert
national parce qu'on à présent on est à
présenter cette élection comme étant un
duel entre la république en marche et le
rassemblement national
donc il ya des gens de chez nous qui
sont allés l'un pour soutenir le réseau
sera soumise au national s'en est
extrait mire et puis d'autres pour
souvenir mâcon parce qu'ils ne voulaient
pas de vue du rassemblement national
mais c'est clair ça c'est clair mais moi
en ce qui concerne le choix le choix de
force que j'avais bel ami ça ne m'a
absolument pas choqué didier parisse
entre un quart et un tiers des électeurs
d'emmanuel macron à la présidentielle
son parti à cette élection
chez europe écologie et ils ont été
remplacés dans votre électorat par à peu
près un quart des lecteurs de françois
fillon à la présidentielle en gros est
ce que ça veut dire que la république en
marché devenu totalement un parti de
droite et que vous êtes la nouvelle udf
non je crois pas dit qu'ils venaient de
la gauche a vu plus qu'en mars
comment vous vivez ça quand même réagir
sur ce que vient de dire monsieur on
peut dire si une élection qui a été
marquée par la communication par tout un
tas de choses ça permette pas faire d'
analyse d'ailleurs je vois à quel point
il est difficile de répondre à vos
questions sur ce nouveau sur ce terrain
là je pense qu'il ya un mouvement de
fond les français ne souhaitent plus
cette espèce de dichotomie historique à
laquelle on était confrontés les
français veulent quoi ils veulent du
pragmatisme
ils veulent des réponses de réponse y
compris sur l'écologie de réponse sur
les soucis du quotidien
ils veulent des réponses claires ils
veulent un cap et le cap il est fixé par
par notre mouvement politique un
mouvement large on a l'air d'être
surpris de
2 de ce que certains veulent y venir
mais la république certains viennent
pendant d'autres embarquent oui synthèse
mais la république en marche c'est déjà
en soi franchement moi l'assemblée
nationale a à côté de moi j'ai des gens
qui étaient des jus pays ce qui était l
r j'en ai qui comme moi viennent plutôt
du ps c'est déjà un regroupement
donc ce regroupement se confine presque
plus d'électeurs de gauche de la
présidentielle il ya un truc bien
évidemment salle saint-jean suis une
expression peut-être une modeste
expression mais une expression il ya
encore bien sûr des électeurs de gauche
dire qu'il n'ya pas eu une forme de
mutation sur cette élection là je
comprends pourquoi parce que en réalité
on a un parti de droite qui n'a pas
compris l'évolution des mentalités qui
ne sait plus comprendre la société
française et qui étend déboussolés c'est
assez largement reporter sur sa gauche
ou une partie sur sa droite
c'est très clair le ps et les partis de
gauche qui font quand même un sport
complet relativement correct mais il
faut les agglomérer mais il faut
demeurer quoi il faut admirer des
différences parce qu'il n'y a eu aucune
plateforme commune entre glucksmann et
un nom expliquez moi comment ils ont pu
faire pour arriver à ce résultat
on voit que vous regardez toujours vers
la gauche donc mais ça montre quand même
que ça montre quand même que ces gens là
n'ont pas su eux non plus capter les
aspirations fondamentales des français
qui sont des aspirations de clarté
d'évolution de modernisme de travail
positif pour pour faire que la france se
relève et elle est en train de se
relever sylvie beaulieu et ont évoqué
avec jacques baudouin tout à l'heure
c'est à dire la volonté d'essayer de
garder une partie de leur électorat
ça a marché pour que les gens viennent
pas chez vous mais finalement ça vous
profite quand est-ce que macro a réussi
s'est effondrée la gauche et la droite
c'est à dire qu'il a tout balayé
après avoir écrasé la gauche il a
maintenant écrasé la droite et on en
arrive aujourd'hui c'est la droite vient
de recevoir un coup un coup fatal
on est bien d'accord et à ce stade je
crois que les concitoyens doivent faire
un choix
c'est à dire qu'ils doivent soit choisir
le camp des fédéralistes les euros
fédéraliste des mondialistes de
l'immigration avec macron ou alors
revenir auprès des nationaux que nous
représentons pour une europe des nations
pour la défense d'une identité et c'est
ce qu'a fait thierry mariani et on s'en
félicite parce que c'est quelqu'un
d'exceptionnel au sein de notre
méditerranée quelqu'un qui vient des
républicains avant d'être qu'il l'était
plus on aura de l'autre je les entrées
sur l'aide sur les cartes
jacques baudouin est ce qu'un espace
vital pour les républicains encore
entrevue le rassemblement national et la
république en marche entre eu droit hier
bien entendu c'était le chemin qui avait
été initié par laurent wauquiez
bon c'est vrai que c'est avec nous à
l'exposer à droite laurent wauquiez
comme il s'est pas posé au milieu on
n'est pas à gauche à c'est certain ça
c'est certain mais bon à droite la
puissance de la droite extrême et à la
droite républicaine
c'est pas moi c'est pas moi c'est pas
c'est pas madame donc non moi je pense
que nous avons toujours alors je vais
vous dire une chose moi je suis un
ancien du rpr des crises comme ça on en
a connu à l'appel on s'est toujours
relevé je suis content il n'y a pas de
problème claire mallard pas parlant
aussi de je vous ai vu sourire quand je
parlais de ses électeurs de la
présidentielle qui était venu chez
europe écologie est ce que du coup ça
fait finalement de vous le pôle central
de la gauche
alors ni jason été très clair il a dit
mon boulot c'est pas de refaire la
gauche plurielle
parce que est ce que ce n'est pas un
danger pour vous et europe écologie de
vous placer en position d'une espèce de
nouvelles nouveau pôle de gauche mais on
est écologiste c'est à dire que les
choses ne se pose pas comme ça qu'est ce
qui se passe on voit que la république
en marche en fait est un agglomérat des
des politiques de social-démocratie de
droite qu'on a vécu pendant 30 ans ce
que nous on appelle le productiviste qui
se retrouve très bien au sein de la
république en marche
ce pôle productiviste libre échangiste
qui mène la politique que l'on connaît
jusqu'à présent qui a détruit notre
environnement qui hack accru les
inégalités sociales et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on alimente les
nationalismes et le populisme d'extrême
droite donc ces deux systèmes s'alimente
et quelle est l'alternative en face et
c'est pour ça que je récuse complètement
la bipolarisation de la vie politique
l'alternative aujourd'hui le seul projet
d'espoir c'est l'écologie politique et
on le voit bien avec ce vote c'est un
signal pour passer à l'action
pourquoi aujourd'hui des écologistes
évidemment ils votent pour un parti
écologiste
parce que tout le monde en parle en
parle notamment la république en marche
le président nous agissons les parties
ont essayé de faire de l'écologie
mais bercy mais personne n'agit pas il
ya aussi le parti au pouvoir qui
agissent mais en attendant on est au
parlement européen on agit et les
électeurs l'ont vu et c'est bien pour ça
qu'ils ont voté pour les écologistes
parce que quand on est au pouvoir on
agit et je vais venir aussi mais je
reviendrai tout à l'heure sur l'exemple
de damien carême qui est un vrai rempart
contre la montée de l'extrême droite et
1105 le maire de grande synthe qui est
aujourd'hui élu eurodéputé europe et
vous bien paru oui je pense que ma kron
a fait de l'écologie un peu tardivement
et c'est ce qui je pense a fait basculer
les électeurs chez chez jadot
franchement je pense on peut parler
moi je n'accepte où les débats au
contraire mais on peut aussi agir et en
deux ans je crois que la politique que
nous avons menées y compris dans le
domaine de la transition écologique dont
chacun reconnaît que c'est c'est notre
avenir enfin il faut qu'on le jre aucun
doute plus personne ne le saurait dire
c'est un sou sujet bon
mais il ya l'action et nous sommes donc
tombe d'action nous avons fait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup il reste beaucoup à
faire
voilà dix ans qu'il n'est pas impossible
que vous soyez alliés au parlement
européen alors 6 la majorité va se faire
entre république en marche et enfin à
elle des oeufs et ja souvenons nous que
souvenons nous que les verts avaient
frais sur deux choses
souvenons nous par une nouvelle majorité
au parlement européen envoyer l'image
derrière nous ça va être complètement
différente ce qui se passait jusqu'à
vouloir faire de transition mais quelle
est la suite il ya la suite des
élections municipales mersey chaîne et
on est quand même nation vous avez
raison monsieur mollet la suite de la
reconstruction au niveau européen
c'est quand même assez étrange la
manière dont ça se passe la capacité du
front national je continue à dire ferons
tout ce que je vois pas y ait le
rassemblement n'a qu'à passer du front
national a aggloméré y compris salvini y
compris les polonais qui qui refuse
absolument la position qui est prise par
notre le parti français ça marche pas
ici même nigel farage est quand même un
petit peu un petit peu surprenant et on
va voir comment les choses se déroulent
au plan européen
moi je pense que entre gens de bonne
composition qui ont le même objectif
effectivement il est majeur capitale de
sauver notre planète de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour ne pas rester les bras
ballants sur cette question là on verra
à leur rapprochement qui seront alors
vous avez vous pensez pas qu emmanuel
macron un petit peu isolé en europe en
ce moment je pense que c'est le phare de
l'europe actuellement
c'est c'est peut-être le seul d'en avoir
un port des convictions à regret raison
d'assises ray merci monsieur et c'est
sans doute le seul à avoir de vraies
convictions ne serait être capable
d'entraîner un mouvement européen qui il
est vrai était populisme qui sont
développées partout est en grand danger
c'est le pouvoir qui n'est pas arrivé en
tête pour ces européennes quand même
pardon c'est le seul au pouvoir
actuellement qui n'est pas arrivé en
tête au maire de sézanne ap annoncé cinq
ans même si l'édition vous en dise
c'est presque exceptionnel le résultat
fait par le parti au pouvoir sur cette
élection
c'est très exceptionnel dans la mesure
où on ajoutant 20 milliards d'euros en
direction des ménages et ne pas arriver
à être premier
si on sait bien que vous le
reconnaissiez c'est bien le look non
ménopausées vous en fait c'est de me
faire je vais vous empêcher de refaire
les élections européennes déjà déjà au
pardon merci monsieur la condition qu'on
puisse parler d'europe avec le front
national qui n'a pas dit un mot pendant
la campagne je vous en prie il faut donc
je vais vous parler des élections
municipales qui vont arriver parce que
ce résultat des européennes nous amène
quand même on va le dire à une situation
qui s'annonce inédite en général en
france le pouvoir se fait massacrer à
mi-mandat ce comme ça c'est une
tradition chez nous sauf que déjà la
république en marche a plutôt bien passé
le cap des européennes sauf dans la
nièvre faut le dire certes mais ce n'est
pas le chiffre national
et puis a quasiment pas de mer la
république en marche à sanctionner donc
ça nous donne forcément une des
municipales inédite
didier paris ce bon ils vous ont posé
des questions mais je vous redonne la
parole parce que je voulais quand même
vous poser cette question là c'est quoi
la stratégie du coup pas république en
marche que vous avez pas de mer donc
c'est quoi vous allez franchisés des
gens vous allez les punir comme a dit
gilles boyer s'ils sont pas avec le
président vous allez faire quoi
toutes les positions sont possibles la
manière dont je vois les choses moi
c'est surtout pas de punir qui que ce
soit c'est encore une fois on a une adn
un adn qui est très clair c'est vrai que
c'est un mouvement qui n'existe que
depuis deux ans donc il ya tout à
construire nous n'avons pas de d'élus
locaux
certains ont fait le passage certains
l'ont exprimé mais d'élus locaux élus
sous l'étiquette public en marche
ça nous manque clairement et la
construction d'un parti historique comme
le vôtre par exemple elle s'est basée
sur sur l'élection locale
donc ce que je crois moi c'est qu'il ya
un pas de raison de mettre forcément en
avant une étiquette politique dès lors
qu'il ya eu dès lors qu'on efface une
plateforme qui est large de st
regroupement de bonne volonté sur des
sur des options local dès lors qu'on
adhère à une plateforme nationale qui
est une plate forme de progrès
d'évolution de prague
il faudra adhère il faudra adhérer une
plateforme il faut la voir
il faudra quelque part reconnaître le
mouvement dans lequel on accepte de
s'inscrire
je sais pas quelle forme ça prendra à
sharp achats moi je suis en train de
travailler sur sur ma circonscription
sur madame de boules qui avait le
meilleur résultat de bourgogne franche
comté au titre de la république en
marche plus de 27 points
il est clair que c'est pas une liste la
république en marche mais sioniste dont
le socle est composée par un certain
nombre de militants et qui derrière
vagues l'eau mais ray plus large c'est
évident
c'est gilles beaulieu au front national
aux municipales et c'est pas toujours
facile
un jour qu'ils allaient alors vous vous
vous allez faire quoi vous allez aller
piocher chez mécontente des républicains
a tendu la main marine marine le pen a
tendu la main maintenant on n'a pas
besoin foncièrement de dlr pour monter
des listes est pour eux mais pour gagner
des villes pour gagner on a gagné des
listes sans eux dans différentes régions
et c'est pas là le problème
maintenant nous on a déjà des petites
idées de là où on va aller sans pour
autant se calquait discret en côte d'or
reste qu'en côte-d'or il ya des mères
qui viennent vous parlez pour les
municipales oui on évoque déjà certaines
choses oui tout à fait et ça on est dans
l'est dans les discussions dans
l'ouverture
le rassemblement est un mouvement
d'ouverture donc on attend
jacques baudouin 60% des villes de plus
de 9000 habitants sont à droite en
france depuis dernières municipales mais
après 8 % aux européennes il va se
passer quoi en gros ça va être le grand
d étiquetage les gens vont dire non mais
en fait je suis plus à l'ère des
héritages et négociations discrètes sur
la plateforme
si on part de la nièvre on parlera après
parce que c'est intéressant la nièvre
mais en général
tout dépend de la
de la conduite des convictions des élus
aient l'air si certains nous quittent
parce qu'il ya le moindre souffle de
vent
je suis un peu que c'est certain mais je
pense qu'il y en a qui n'ont pas attendu
notamment dans la nièvre les élections
européennes pour suivre le vent alors je
vais prendre un exemple autres par
exemple de quelqu'un qui est la
république en mars le maire de nevers
vous avez des gens qui sont des gens de
conviction quand même chez vous ou des
dernières sénatoriales il a quand même
fait perdre les deux camps des deux
candidats de votre parti au profit des
socialistes
chapeau alors si si vous avez les mêmes
ambitions chez certains ont du mal à
parler de moi moi je moi je vais vous
dire je vous dire sinon à les conduire
si raison par les candidats qui ont des
convictions qui prendront les tickets
terre et puis un point c'est tout ce
qu'ils veulent nous quitter nous quitte
qu'est ce que les convives parce qu'on
le vaut donc ne veulent pas ils le
feront sa vie avait les jambes ya les
gens de conviction et il ya les gens de
la gamelle chacun choisira un monsieur
pâris vous avancez donc masqué sans
étiquette sur les minima non c'est très
clair vous aurez des listes attendez
c'est un mouvement large contrairement
aux autres donc il faut bien qu'on une
stratégie n'arrive à gagner avec 500
agen 10 non mais je pense que vous
présenterez pas des candidats partout
parce que les résultats enfin la gestion
municipale par le front national me
paraît pas avoir été partout exemplaire
donc faudra choisir peut-être
sélectionné peut-être pas refaire les
erreurs initiales que vous aviez fait la
dernière fois mais ça ça vous appartient
donc il y aura des endroits où
clairement c'est un candidat lrm parce
que c'est lui qui a construit et qui a
bâti le combat politique locale d'autres
si le maire est gentil non non
permanents pas du tout si l'armée santé
ou oui ça veut rien dire cesser sinon
c'est quoi une élection c'est pour la
gagner une élection c'est pour la gagner
au profit non pas d'un parti d'un
mouvement au profit de la population
locale qui a besoin que les choses et je
vous confie des magistrats car elle
attend patiemment et moi ça m'a donné
rien de savoir ce que veut faire europe
écologie pour cette élection avec
yannick jadot qui a lève qui allait
assez
fort il a déclaré dans le monde nous
voulons conquérir et exercer le pouvoir
c'est assez nouveau chez vous ça
implique de d'avoir une stratégie qui
est vraiment d'aller chercher donc devil
bats la stratégie elle est classe que
jusqu'à maintenant seuls en gros vous
avez jamais pu gagner des villes ce qui
va se passer c'est que grenoble on a on
a depuis quelques temps quelques mois
sur cette élection européenne
une ligne politique qui est clair c'est
de mettre l'écologie comme centre de
gravité pour redéfinir notre économie et
les politiques publiques
donc c'est clair la bon j'entends un peu
tout le monde on voit pas bien il y aura
une plateforme y aura chez pas quoi nous
c'est simple c'est que on souhaite
rassembler fédérer toutes les bonnes
volontés qui feront de l'adaptation au
changement climatique de la création de
nouvelles solidarités et de l'innovation
démocratique la priorité du projet quand
vous dis à toutes les bonnes volontés ça
veut dire que c'est pas réservé à aux
maires de gauche par exemple le maire
socialiste qui vont avoir grand besoin
des deux ça peut être avec tout le monde
à partir du mans une feuille de route où
l'écologie doit être le centre de
gravité avec les exigences
aujourd'hui les jeunes qui ont voté
massivement pour nous ils nous disent
pas je suis de droite je suis de gauche
et nous dit ils nous disent bougez vous
pour sauver le climat c'est une rupture
sur l'écologie on est d'accord il n'y a
pas de rupture ya les solidarités
l'innovation démocratique la justice
sociale et la majorité 52 euros bien sûr
on est dans la continuité de ce qu'on
porte
sauf qu aujourd hui mais jusqu'à
maintenant des était une force de la
gauche clairement vous êtes une force de
la gauche - la justice sociale est ce
que la droite conservatrice va se
retrouver sur la justice sociale et la
justice fiscale
est-ce que la république en marche dont
on combat le projet global donc
d'ailleurs je le dis que tu te dis très
clairement on veut absolument pas
bricoler des projets municipaux avec des
gens dont on conteste le projet global
on a une feuille de route avec des
principes une cohérence qu'on va
continuer et toutes les bonnes volontés
qui souhaitent travailler sur ses
exigences
on travaille avec c'est pas plus
difficile que ça voilà ce qu'ils
feraient des accords entre 1 je viens
simplement de dire qu'on aura une
feuille de route et qu'on travaillera
avec brio ses poches
après moi je me garde bien d'aller dans
les stratégies des autres on porte la
mienne on porte la nôtre elle est
cohérente
elle fédère aujourd'hui et je pense
qu'elle peut être une vraie alternatif
est effectivement yannick jadot a été
très critiquée en particulier à la
france est soumise sur le fait de de
rappeler qu'un certain nombre de partis
étaient faussement écologistes vous vous
souvenez vous êtes d'accord avec lui là
dessus tout le monde à tout le monde a
essayé de se faire dire effectivement
l'écologie tout le monde en parle et
ceux qui agissent
c'est des écologistes et comme je le
redis vous allez dire que je me répète
mais on l'a vu au parlement européen on
mène des combats on gagne des combats
donc les gens votent pour nous
l'écologie c'est pas des déclarations
c'est de l'action
après fort heureusement et on se réjouit
effectivement que il ya des partis qui
ont pris conscience qu'ils aient
anciennement une gauche productiviste
il ya toute une gauche productiviste qui
n'avait pas saisi les enjeux
environnementaux qui effectivement
aujourd'hui les prennent en compte
après je vais pas non plus commenter les
petites phrases et ses des uns et des
autres je rassure notre ligne politique
les décisions se prendront
collectivement on va avancer on va
maintenir cette dynamique et de toute
façon une urgence climatique et
franchement les échéances électorales à
côté de l'enjeu sur lequel on doit se
mobiliser
franchement voilà je pense qu'il faut
prendre de la hauteur par rapport à tout
ça didier paris c'est ce qu'il ya des
objectifs chiffrés par la république en
marche dans une région comme la
bourgogne à les exercices pratiques une
ville swallow dijon vous êtes arrivé
trait aux européennes avec un air chaud
qui ne se passera quoi par exemple un
joint tout pour dire ça ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'on est oui mais on sait
difficile de reporter automatiquement
aussi si je prends par exemple des
résultats europe ecologie les verts en
2009 aux européennes ses 17 points 2014
9 points la 13 points ça fait pas pour
autant une grande masse de zimmer
écologie les verts donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que ça veut dire qu'il
ya pas deux il n'y a pas de
communication directe entre les deux
nous ne faisons rien nous dire ça qu'il
faut faire attention aux résultats des
européennes n'est pas le plaqué sur la
nuit
bien sûr les impôts c'est un signe c'est
un signe mais c'est pas un signe
suffisant
on ne peut pas comparer la situation de
2009 et 2019 je suis bien ici mollet
mais l'environnement aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe la crise
climatique
elles touchent le quotidien le fait
partie du quotidien des français ils la
ressentent en 2009 ce n'était pas le cas
on est multiplication des sécheresses
vous aviez fait 17 points donc il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut justement il y
avait déjà une poussée très fort non
mais elles connaissent quasiment ciel
devant la tête de et müller a jolly la
commet eh bien vous en aurez texte et
vous vous attardez vous entendez la
musique tout ça va nous ouvrir
directement sur les mois qui viennent et
bien sûr que beaucoup de choses vont se
jouer encore pour ces élections
municipales
et ça va sûrement démarré beaucoup plus
fort à la rentrée merci à tous les
quatre devenu commenter ces élections et
nous parler de vos stratégies la
politique continue sur france 3 après le
journal parti national francis letellier
recevra rafale et de raphaël glucksmann
qui monnaie européenne la liste ps place
publique on reste donc dans notre sujet
du jour au revoir et bon dimanche